what a wild adventure i guess you you've
been on in the last little while
can you describe us how you felt and
like the balance of emotions that you
were going through
when you finally decided to speak your
truth and say that you know how you
wanted to live your life
there was a major fear the biggest
supporter i have and still have is
priscilla my wife
she is just my rock and it's because she
was so
loving and so caring so supportive that
i was able to speak it
i remember the first time i said it out
loud
not to priscilla but somebody else was
one of our neighbors
it took me five minutes to spit it out
because i was so
fearful of the reaction because society
has just beaten into us that it's not
okay
there is that whole phase there and
every time i told someone it got a
little
easier i also want to talk about mia how
has she seen
and supported you through all this mia
has been
amazing through the whole thing and of
course just like priscilla
she had a range of emotions but i have
had her support since
the way that you were looked at in the
past your role your job
as a superstar what was going through
your head when you thought
well i'm gonna go public with this and
now all those people that saw me
you know i'm gonna be sharing my new
life with them i wonder what they're
gonna think or did that
cross your mind when i was ready to tell
my story
i had this gut feeling that can't be
described any other way than divine
to just be transparent and i knew in my
heart and in my
soul that 99 of the people would be
welcoming they'd be understanding and
they would support i just knew that if i
was transparent and truthful
100 there was nothing to hide that i
would be accepted
and we would start changing the world
and that's exactly what happened
what would you like to say um to people
who are struggling
for whatever reasons they have in their
lives to
live their truth there is hope on the
other side
it can be painful and it can be
traumatic
but hang in there know that you're loved
know that you're not alone
know that there's a light at the end of
the tunnel